[Música]
de ser el origen de la pandemia global
wuhan ha pasado a ser un lugar que desde
hace meses está libre del virus y un año
después de que comenzará el brote una
gran multitud pudo asistir a este
tradicional punto de la ciudad para
recibir el año nuevo
en 2020 es verdad que sufrimos mucho
pero nos levantamos espero que nada
similar ocurra este año
en europa se vivieron situaciones
inéditas como en madrid en donde por
primera vez se prohibieron las
celebraciones de año nuevo en plazas o
calles públicas y el festejo se redujo a
un concierto sin público y solo con unos
cuantos espectadores desde la distancia
además con una nutrida presencia de la
policía vigilando el comienzo del toque
de queda desde la una y media de la
madrugada los que no se podían acostar
muy tarde eran estos valientes que
querían darle la bienvenida al 2021 con
un buen baño desde italia países bajos
pasando por portugal algunos pocos se
dieron un chapuzón cumpliendo con las
tradiciones locales en américa latina'
la imagen es la soledad de ciudad de
mexico la capital mexicana vive desde
hace unos días un cierre de la actividad
no esencial como consecuencia de una
ocupación hospitalaria calles vacías
casi como viviendo un luto en una nación
en donde nuevo coronavirus se ha cobrado
más de 125 mil muertos en río de janeiro
hubo pocos asistentes para un
espectáculo de fuegos artificiales que
se tuvo que cancelar por el nuevo auge
del cob y de 19 pero en este hospital de
sao paulo había menos espacio para
celebrar y en vez de ello esas
enfermeras rindieron un minuto de
silencio por las víctimas de la pandemia